deep in the Hawks end Phillips to Nick Felino
and it was JT Miller who blasted Isaac Phillips
at the back of the play as Felino puts one on
Thatcher Demco hit Vancouver conuts player Noah
julson in the face now the puck off the Stick
of Tyler Johnson Conor Murphy plays it now off
the side of the net julson tries to whisk it away
Phillips puts one wide of the cage teral now by JT
Miller momentarily but Lucas reel starts to break
out right to left reel knocked Away by demo Bard
Taps the buck for Philip kurf thrown to boiler
on the wing he curls around to the wall Kaiser
now for boiler looking for a stick he finds
Bard and the redirect by Tyler Johnson denied
and Johnson's blade is a little bit flat and if
he gets turned over just a little bit more like
a maybe a 58 degree wedge it goes right over that
left Pad but instead what a play Massive save by
by Demco we're still playing on a delayed penalty
Bard saved Demco rebound into the corner for Tyler
Johnson that's still impressive here's Tyler
Johnson top of the circle down low for radish
back to Johnson onetime kurashev soaked up by
Thatcher Demco drifting to his righty curls
around guarded by Pew Suter Tyler Johnson into
the glove of Bard Bard lets it rip rebound weak
side Tyler Johnson oh this looks good here five
forwards on the ice Bard SHO oh save Demco Puck
pops up in the air now Felino down low great off
the Mas Bard Kev open Tyler Johnson kicked up and
out of play by Thatcher Demco playing in his 30th
and HL game this afternoon Alias Pon now looking
for mcka and that shot knocked Away by morazzi
here's Felino now who plays the puck to Joey
Anderson Back Down feno's way in the trapezoid
plucked off the the apron and now Jason Dickinson
banked up to Phillips Phillips bounces it down
low bino looking for the puck it was stripped by
Philip fonic but Anderson gets it right back
in the crease fito scores what a takeaway by
Joey Anderson and Felino slots it home for his
fifth goal of the Season some meat and potatoes
work down low winning this battle against Herona
cuz he got some help from Anderson Herona falls
out Anderson plays it right to the far post and
this time Demco doesn't get a pat on it it looks
eerily similar to the play on the PowerPlay from
Bard to Johnson but you can see the angle of the
blade of the Stick of right there a little chip
off the heel opened up a little bit over the pad
under the glove and in the net for a one- nothing
lead shot behind the net rebound Conor Garin and
it's Anthony boiler up ice game opening up here
out of the timeout T Taylor radish besser Miller
lets it rip blocked by Conor Murphy that hurt
it might be a five on two now Miller again Pon
scores that was executed perfectly but they
took advantage of a of a wounded defenseman
right there in Murphy who that one timer by
JT Miller had a lot on and that's stung right
there on the outside of the right leg and
now he's he's got to get himself up right
there but now you you see the scene that
goes across because there's a lot of Gap
between the the three right there far beyond
the Stick of Dickinson and Phillips and there
is no stop in this one one of the most lethal
wrist shots and a wide open net on the short
side Tyler Johnson over to Bard
Felino just off the crease Bard
passes to kurashev over to Bard top
of the circle he shoots save rebound
score another multi- gold game for
Nick Felino this one on the power
play first power play the last five it didn't
looked good the very first one they had with the
five forwards and you can see you start the second
period but D instead of being on the right side
like he was in the first they switch it up he goes
to the other side of the ice Waits hesitates fires
it and watch Felino get good net front presence
here the shot the rebound and he just bangs this
one home and he is uncontested right there to that
doesn't happen very often where he's able to watch
the puck come through Teddy bler flips the puck
up nearly off the scoreboard it hit Dakota Joshua
on the way down to the ice and now Conor Garland
curls with the puck Garland winds up redirected
by Dakota Joshua and Vancouver scores this line
absolutely redh hot in their last three games now
and basically on this play here Connor Garland
on the left side the ice right here played for
Rick toet in Arizona with the coyotes he waits
he buys some time and then just kind of a half
clap slapper right there I mean I mean there was
no intent to shoot this on net and score a goal
he's looking for a stick right there oh that is a
brilliant play by Garland everybody's looking for
this to be on net look at the way he just moved
his hands at the last second Chris to the right
everybody think that's going on net so you're
trying to take that look and finally hoglander
from behind his own neet Myers with a broken
stick on the ice in the Vancouver Zone Puck
pocketed by besser besser fires Vancouver scores
again it's 3 to2 well and can he fire the puck I
mean these are clean looks right here there's
been no real sustained pressure no feel for it
and the ones that have happened have jumped out
of nowhere here this odd man breaking little pump
fake right there and it just blows by the glove of
morazzi and besser can fire it and this one here
off oh it did didn't even go blow off the bottom
of the glove it just was Rising a skipping Puck
like a stone into the corner of the Vancouver
end cev battling julson but darn in the crease
the puck slips out trying to keep the puck in
the attacking zone of the Hawks Nikita zadorov
for JT Miller and a big save by morazzi he's
got some Puck marks on the front of his jersey
Blackhawks have been peppering him this afternoon
good position another twoam hits in in the chest
now a chance for Alias Pon and Suter sends the
puck back to Tyler Myers and Vancouver scores
again a shot from the point and the Canucks lead
4-2 MV ends up going to the front of the that 65
you can see there's the first shot by Pon and
it's stopped by the stick now keep your eye
on this shot by Meyers it looked to me like it
might have been going wide from my vantage point
now boy you got Pon and you've got mcka he went
first oh yeah there's the second redirection I
believe Kev skate to stick and finally some
breathing room for Kev working around PE
Suter boiler leaves it for Bard 40 seconds on the
power play Bard looking for a sliver Cole Gutman
scores a power play goal for Cole Gutman
his second goal of the season and the Hawks
are right back in this thing with four white
sweaters there Bard finds his way and weaves
his way through he drops it back and Gutman
with a slick little wrist shot to the stick
side here's the play that actually rolled off
the blade of bardan perfectly to the oncoming
Gutman there but that is a great job to weave
its way through the Hawks have had trouble on
the entries because of the fourman stand up at
the blue line by the Vancouver Canucks on the
PK bouncing Puck JT Miller after it in deep
Brock besser a Tapper and a save by moric and
another brilliant save on the rebound by hogland
by Vancouver on the play Let's Take a look at the
Stick of moraza he pushed it to his right and
now hog oh my goodness Co collides with Felino
julson loses positioning theres Johnson Felino now
behind the net looking for a man in front and re
Johnson is stopped by Demco Tyler Johnson there
we go Philip Roose off the glove radish blocked
by Demco and bler now off the wall and Pon for
Miller shooting at an empty net it's blocked by
Zev but 3 seconds left That's All She Wrote Hawks
battle but fall up short 4 to three to Vancouver